si vous êtes créateur si vous êtes
créatif si vous voulez faire des vidéos
au mode portrait au mode paysage très
facilement avec une super stabilisation
et sans galérer tout ça avec votre
smartphone et bien j'ai le produit qui
vous faut c'est celui-là c'est le dji
Osmo Mobile 6 ou alors dji en ce moment
Mobile 6 mobile c'est bien c'est quand
même à ça comme nous alors en fait le
truc qui est très très cool c'est que
c'est un stabilisateur en stabilisateur
sur trois axes c'est déjà la sixième
génération on a eu un paquet avant et
qui est extrêmement mais extrêmement
extrêmement facile à venir utiliser très
complet on peut faire énormément de
choses avec et vous allez voir ce
produit vraiment super et c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui réalisait en
partenariat avec dji dji m'a dit tiens
bon monsieur gros est-ce que tu voudrais
venir tester notre
Osmo Mobile 6 montrer l'étendue des
possibilités qu'on a avec tout ce qu'on
peut faire alors en tant qu'amoureux de
tech de nouveaux produits et d'outils
pour les créateurs et bien j'ai dit oui
tout de suite d'ailleurs en parlant
d'outils pour les créateurs il y a pas
longtemps je vous ai fait celui-là c'est
le dji Mike aussi extraordinaire je vous
invite à venir le découvrir et pour
l'instant aujourd'hui on se concentre là
dessus et ça c'est super
[Musique]
parce que globalement j'ai envie de dire
par on s'en fiche parce qu'on connaît
c'est très joli c'est une boîte c'est
sympathique ça vous montre un peu tous
qu'on peut bien faire avec on voit les
différents cas d'usage et surtout voyez
un peu les nouveautés tout ce que vous
avez à regarder hop là on voit bien là
on a bien la stérilisation sur trois
axes on a un lancement rapide il est
portable il est pliable on est actif
track 5.0 qui est super cool des tutos
on peut guider très facilement et puis
on a un extinction Road alors regardez
la bête la bête c'est ça c'est ça votre
petit
osmobile 6 le premier truc qui est
vachement bien ça c'est une nouveauté
c'est à dire que pour venir l'allumer
vous avez pas besoin de laisser votre
doigt appuyer ça vous pouvez le faire si
vous voulez mais bon il y a une autre
façon qui est beaucoup plus simple vous
prenez regardez vous levez et il
s'allume directement ça c'est vraiment
génial parce qu'on gagne un temps de
dingue moi le truc est super important
ton Créateur c'est de se dire ok si je
vois un truc qui me plaît je veux filmer
je veux pas devoir attendre que mon
objet s'allume je veux pas de attendre
de pouvoir y aller donc je prends et je
vais y aller directement donc là
regardez hop je le PLIE c'est un
directement mais directement c'est
vraiment instantané je le prends je
l'ouvre il s'allume directement donc le
truc est quand même vachement bien donc
ça c'est le premier point donc là vous
voyez j'ai mon stabilisateur qui est
allumé maintenant le truc qui va être
super cool c'est ce petit accessoire que
je vais venir utiliser pour mettre mon
smartphone alors regardez il y a deux
choses déjà le premier truc qu'on voit
c'est que vous avez un petit connecteur
là vous voyez ici vous avez un petit
petite pin là vous avez également ici là
cet espace pour le connecteur donc vous
le prenez hop vous le mettez en face il
se monte c'est hyper solide hein ça
bougera pas et c'est super sérieux alors
autre truc vous voulez venir mettre
votre smartphone et bien vous prenez
votre smartphone surtout pour faire un
peu gaffe c'est qu'ici vous indique là
c'est le côté où il y a l'appareil photo
donc vous prenez hop là vous tirez vous
le mettez comme ça là il est bien
positionné je n'ai plus qu'à venir le
mettre comme ça j'ai bien ma
correspondance au niveau des petits
points et hop là c'est parti mon Tintin
une fois qu'il est positionné et bien
regardé j'ai mon application directement
ici qui est lancé c'est dji amimo qui va
me permettre de tout filmer très très
facilement j'ai plein de modes
différents ça je trouve ça très cool
parce que regardez pouvoir faire de
l'hyperlapse faire du timelapse faire du
diner zoom ça c'est du Dolly avoir un
effet de lit en fait au niveau de votre
zoom ça c'est aussi très très cool je
vais avoir le ralenti la vidéo également
dans sachant que je viens choisir je
peux monter jusqu'à 4K à 60 images par
seconde directement ici dans
l'application puis j'ai plein d'infos au
niveau de mon ouverture au niveau de mon
ISO et compagnie un mode photo un autre
panoramique et un mode Story qui
m'aidera à venir à faire de la création
très très facilement donc là est super
bien parce que c'est vraiment un outil
pour les créatifs un outil pour les
créateurs qui veulent pas se prendre la
tête et qui veulent une solution hyper
complète alors autre truc qui est super
bien vous avez ce qu'on appelle ici
l'extension Road l'extension Road en
fait c'est quoi si vous vous dites ok
j'ai mon stabilisateur qui est comme ça
mais moi je veux filmer un truc qui est
un peu plus haut sauf que je fais pas
garder le bras pendant des heures lever
comme ça vous voyez c'est un peu galère
bien en fait vous prenez vous avez
l'extinction Road et là ça vous permet
de lever quand même vachement plus haut
donc c'est très très cool et si vous
trouvez que c'est toujours passé haut et
bien vous avez des trucs là que vous
venez mettre en plus dessus alors ça ce
truc là c'est génial parce que au-delà
vous voyez devenir rajouter encore et
d'avoir une énorme perche où là vous
pouvez aller pas hyper loin et bien en
plus vous le prenez vous l'ouvrez ça se
pose sur une table donc là il est génial
parce que comme vous avez de l'actif
track 5.1 et bien ça fait un petit pied
pour qu'il vienne vous suivre pour qu'il
vienne filmer faire tout ce que vous
voulez donc pour le Time labse c'est
bien c'est hyper stable pour venir vous
filmer lorsque vous vous allez prendre
la parole et que vous avez besoin
d'avoir les mains libres et ben il va
également venir vous suivre donc c'est
pareil c'est une fonctionnalité qui est
super intéressante voyez là je suis à la
hauteur j'ai plus qu'à prendre hop là
voilà je le prends je le pose il se
positionne très facilement et là j'ai
plus qu'à l'utiliser pour venir filmer
il est stabilisé c'est vachement
pratique et dernier élément est pas des
moindres vous avez une petite sacoche
pour venir l'emmener partout avec vous
parce qu'ici l'idée c'est la mobilité on
filme avec son smartphone on veut
pouvoir l'emmener partout avec soi et
bien vous le mettez là dedans vous
prenez vous enlevez juste ce truc là
vous pouvez garder avec vous ou pas vous
glissez dans son petit sac et vous êtes
parti pour des séances de création où
vous voulez quand vous voulez très
facilement et je trouve ça génial
[Musique]
c'est que c'est hyper smooth lorsque je
vais venir filmer comme ça vous voyez je
me déplace je peux bouger je peux venir
le monter je peux venir le descendre
c'est hyper smooth c'est pour les
créatif c'est génial pour ceux qui
veulent des beaux plans des plans fluide
c'est vraiment top après il y a un autre
truc c'est que je peux switcher entre
l'avant et l'arrière au niveau de la
caméra de mon smartphone là je suis en
train de filmer l'arrière on le voit
avec la caméra derrière hop j'appuie ici
je rappuie sur ma gâchette je passe sur
ma caméra de selfie donc là regardez sur
ma caméra de selfie il me reconnaît il
voit ma tête si je descend comme j'ai de
l'actif track il va me suivre si je mets
ma tête sur le côté il va me suivre donc
le truc est vraiment génial comme ça je
peux switcher très facilement de
l'arrière à l'avant sans me prendre la
tête et autre truc qui est vraiment
génial et bien c'est que je peux changer
de direction j'appuie deux fois hop je
suis en format portrait je suis en
format paysage donc je peux pas daté
totalement soit je vais venir filmer
pour Youtube je passe en format paysage
j'appuie deux fois dessus vous voyez ça
tourne deux fois dessus Tik Tok
Instagram Real c'est YouTube short donc
j'ai vraiment le format que je veux en
permanence donc l'idée elle est
vachement bien là-dessus regardez par
exemple ici vous voyez bien tout le
cadre qui est situé autour de moi c'est
la reconnaissance de mon visage pour le
tracking pour le suivi en même temps
j'ai toutes les informations j'ai mon
ouverture je vais avoir mon ISO je vais
faire ma correction également et puis
j'appuie hop là deux fois je switch je
tombe de côté et je garde exactement mon
cadre de la même manière je vois le
niveau d'entrée de mon micro j'ai
également l'info de mon enregistrement
je vous à combien j'en suis enfin bref
je trouve ça super bien et hop là voyez
ensuite je viens éteindre j'appuie une
fois sur le bouton du bas je switch je
passe sur la caméra derrière je peux
lancer l'enregistrement à nouveau
regardez je peux venir le bouger très
très facilement ici directement avec ma
petite molette ça c'est cool et puis il
y a une autre fonctionnalité qui est
vraiment géniale ce que vous avez la sur
le côté là vous le voyez là vous avez
cette petite molette ici c'est tout
nouveau et bien ce qui est vraiment
génial pourquoi parce que vous voyez
lorsque je la tourne et bien ça me fera
zoom donc là je peux venir zoomer
directement sur ma caméra donc là je me
vois voyez hop là ça c'est hyper fluide
je viens switcher directement entre mes
objectifs donc là vous voyez je viens
zoomer jusqu'à 1 x 8 je peux venir
dézoomer alors si je veux passer sur
l'ultra grand-angle il faut que j'arrête
l'enregistrement ensuite je peux venir
reculer là je suis sur mon ultra
grand-angle je peux lancer mon
enregistrement et là je peux venir
zoomer jusqu'à mon x 8 très facilement
et là vous voyez je viens switcher et je
trouve ça vachement cool parce que alors
une fois de plus dans l'idée de la
création c'est extrêmement facile je
n'ai qu'à venir tourner ici ma petite
molette et sa switch directement je
trouve ça extrêmement malin alors ça
c'est le premier truc et le deuxième
truc qui est génial c'est que lorsque
j'appuie dessus et bien je change de
mode et là je vais passer en mode pour
faire le point donc là vous voyez
lorsque je tourne ça devient
complètement flou et je viens faire mon
point donc si vous voulez régler votre
point manuellement ici vous pouvez le
faire hop là je vais me rapprocher un
petit peu et là je vais chercher à faire
le point ici je dois redescendre un
petit peu voilà je viens là et voilà je
fais mon point donc ça dépend je fais
vraiment comme je veux je rappuie une
fois dessus je repasse en automatique et
là je suis en mode zoom et je peux venir
zoomer très facilement donc le truc est
extrêmement intuitif je trouve ça
vraiment génial puis c'est vrai que
cette molette elle est comme vachement
bien c'est hyper facile à dire commander
je trouve c'est vraiment génial c'est
une nouveauté cette année qui est venu
mettre dji dans son Osmo by 6 c'est
tellement intuitif tellement malin un
petit appui on tourne très facilement je
vous montre le reste des commandes vous
avez ici votre petit joystick piloter
votre nacelle plus ou moins en haut à
droite à gauche ce que vous voulez c'est
très très pratique c'est vraiment du
mode automatique là c'est le bouton pour
venir journée vous appuyez une fois hop
vous passez caméra avant caméra arrière
vous appuyez deux fois vous venez le
faire tourner paysage ou portrait très
facilement ici on vient enregistrer et
puis là avec le petit bouton vous avez
en réalité quatre modes vous les voyez
regardez ils sont indiqués par des
petites icônes le premier mode c'est le
mode suivant le mode suivre il est super
intéressant si vous voulez que votre
nacelle suive le mouvement de votre
poignée c'est à dire que vous prenez
votre stabilisateur et vous le montez et
vous venez filmer vers le haut il va pas
rester bloqué vers le bas comme ça il va
suivre votre mouvement comme si vous
voulez faire un panoramique avec votre
smartphone donc si vous vous dites tiens
je veux bien filmer je vais venir faire
un panoramique c'est extrêmement facile
vous mettez en mode suivre et hop il va
suivre le mouvement vous rappuyez sur m
et vous avez le mode verrouillage de
l'inclinaison alors ici à la différence
du premier mode lorsque je vais venir
incliner ma poignée et bien la nacelle
va rester en place ça me permet en fait
de venir suivre un objet qui est devant
moi et de pas avoir la nacelle qui se
garer à droite à gauche comme ça je peux
venir bouger incliner directement je
suivrai mon boîtier en face de moi après
je peux dire corriger avec mon petit
joystick voyez je suis comme ça ce qui
fait que j'ai un truc qui est hyper
smooth hyper stable sur ce que je veux
venir filmer et je trouve ça extrêmement
malin troisième mode c'est le mode FPV
le mode FPV c'est le suivi de
l'inclinaison de la ce qui fait que si
je tourne ma poignée comme ça et bien
chez ma nacelle qui va tourner alors
attention l'idée c'est pas de se filmer
comme ça sinon ça fait la nausée mais si
vous voulez faire des inclinaisons vous
arrivez dans des rues pour avoir des
trucs qui bougent comme ça qui va suivre
votre mouvement côté un peu vague vous
pouvez le faire le truc est assez
pratique alors attention si vous voulez
vraiment faire un truc stable qui reste
sur vous ce qu'il faut que vous fassiez
c'est que vous faites un petit carré sur
votre visage comme ça vous allez changer
de mode vous avez l'actif tracking vous
repassez en mode suivre et là vous
pouvez venir bouger lui il bougera pas
il restera donc ça dépend vraiment ce
que vous voulez faire et puis vous avez
un dernier mode c'est le spin shot en
fait ça veut dire faire tourner avec la
poignée donc lorsque vous prenez comme
ça ici et bien vous allez venir faire
bouger avec directement ici votre petit
joystick ce qui fait que je vais avoir
directement et bien ma nacelle qui
tourne très facilement mon smartphone
tourne en fonction de ce que je veux
venir faire et de mes idées créatives et
bien voyez c'est très complet j'ai
quatre modes qui permettront d'aller à
peu près dans tous les univers que je
veux vous voyez là par exemple je le
pose comme ça sur ma table je vais venir
me filmer je veux qu'il me suive je vais
voir même un livre et bien je prends hop
là déjà il est un peu bas par rapport à
moi je viens le monter directement avec
l'extension Road ça c'est plutôt bien
hop là est positionné face à moi
j'appuie il se réveille et j'ai que un
truc à venir faire mais en mode suivi je
vois ma tête je me dessine un petit
rectangle autour de ma tête ça veut dire
que c'est la zone à suivre et ensuite
regardez j'ai plus qu'à me bouger comme
ça et lui il va me suivre directement je
peux lancer mon enregistrement son
appuyant directement sur l'écran soit en
appuyant ici je lance l'enregistrement
et là je suis suivi donc là c'est quand
même vachement cool parce que je peux me
rapprocher comme ça il va me reconnaître
j'ai quand même déplacer tout doucement
tranquillement voyez je me balade un peu
autour de la pièce et là j'ai mon vrai
suivi et c'est génial parce que si je
veux par exemple faire un truc un cours
de cuisine voyez les mains libres et
bien je peux le faire je peux venir me
reculer il va venir me suivre
directement et surtout le tracking a été
amélioré avec cette actif tracking 5.0
ce qui lui permet de venir me suivre
partout où je vais de tous les côtés et
je trouve ça vraiment génial comme ça je
peux venir animer quelque chose
facilement je vous le dis une fois de
plus j'ai les mains libres c'est
vraiment juste ici une super idée et
après je viens ici alors faut que je
fasse gaffe pas là il m'a un peu perdu
il faut pas que j'aille trop vite c'est
un peu la limite du truc mais par contre
pour venir animer pour venir faire
quelque chose très facilement c'est cool
et voyez si par exemple je me tourne on
va se dire merde il m'a perdu il a plus
le visage et pour autant je reviens il
me récupère directement c'est ça
l'amélioration en fait c'est par exemple
si vous avez de longs cheveux noirs vous
retournez et qui voit une masse de
cheveux sur un pull noir c'est encore
pas terrible il y avait vous retrouver
si vous avez un chapeau pareil il va
vous retrouver il va vous suivre il sera
exactement où vous êtes ce que vous
faites et je trouve que l'idée ici elle
est juste géniale et si vous manquez
encore un peu d'inspiration et bien vous
avez des idées directement ici dans
votre application c'est vachement bien
alors vous choisissez votre appareil
parce que j'ai dit déjà il y en a quand
même un paquet on va venir se faire nous
losmo by 5 parce que au moment où je
tourne lorsque 6 n'est pas sorti il est
encore sous embargo donc j'ai pas
dernière mise à jour de l'application au
moment où vous regardez cette vidéo elle
sera déjà là et regarder donc là il vous
donne quelques astuces il vous montre
pour venir à l'utiliser au début des
guides pour venir filmer vous en avez
énormément de tous les côtés vous voyez
ça vous explique comment ajuster la
balance de votre smartphone l’auto
calibration horizontale game ball le
mode de suivi follow mode vous avez
énormément d'astuces donc ça c'est
vachement bien parce qu'en fait il vous
lâche pas dans la nature dji il vous
donne plein d'astuces pour savoir
utiliser au mieux votre bail 6 regardez
vous en avez plein d'astuces de tous les
côtés alors là c'est sur les dji pocket
vous avez plein d'idées créatives et ça
vous marque quels sont les appareil
parce que j'ai déjà il y a beaucoup plus
d'appareils vous avez par exemple de
l'osmo Pocket bah bref énormément et
au-delà de ça vous avez également
l'Académie c'est à dire que vous pouvez
venir apprendre énormément pour venir
utiliser parfaitement bien vos dji Osmo
bye 6 regardez ça si tu juste en haut à
droite vous cliquez sur Academy et là
vous arrivez sur vachement de ressources
celle-là elles sont pour le somme Mobile
5 mais une fois de plus vous les aurez
pour le moment 6 et regarder tout ce que
vous avez il vous montre comment bien
filmé des birolles vous avez des
tutoriels vous en avez en français vous
en avez dans toutes les langues comment
créer un instantané en rotation enfin
bref c'est extrêmement pratique pour
vous aider en fait ce sont les
mouvements de la caméra tu vas voir sur
les idées de création je vais avoir des
choses très avancées si vous voulez
aller un peu plus loin je vais avoir du
basique je vais avoir un guide pour les
débutants donc quel que soit les
ressources dont vous avez besoin vous
les trouverez ici donc le truc est très
très malin alors après vous pouvez venir
éditer directement ici si vous le
souhaitez il y a des modèles mais si on
a une autre application qui vachement
cool c'est l'application Lite cut qui
vous permet de venir éditer vos vidéos
en un coup très facilement il y a des
template notamment pour Instagram ça
c'est très cool aussi regardez par
exemple là hop soit pour plus donc là
vous voyez ça me donne des idées bon ok
c'est des effets des transitions ça peut
être très pratique pour Instagram si tu
vois des trucs sympas pour TikTok pour
YouTube bref à vous de voir et à vous de
libérer votre créativité si vous êtes
créatif si vous êtes créateur si vous
êtes débutant ou confirmé pourquoi pas
que vous voulez filmer avec votre
smartphone et bien ça c'est le must have
c'est l'outil à voir vraiment très
facile d'utilisation très simple avec
plein de modes il est extrêmement cool
c'est le dji c'est l'osmo Mobile 6 s'il
vous intéresse je vous mets un lien bien
évidemment juste en bas dans la
description je vous invite à venir le
découvrir il y a de très nombreux
avantages il y a plein de belles mises à
jour il y a plein de nouveautés
également par rapport à l'osmo by il a 5
le fait de l'ouvrir rapidement je trouve
ça juste génial vous prenez vous ouvrez
tac il est fonctionnel c'est très très
pratique l'extension Road ça c'est aussi
un truc qui est vraiment extraordinaire
parce que lorsque vous voulez venir
filmer bien vous le monter à la hauteur
que vous voulez en fonction des besoins
que vous avez la stabilisation sur trois
axes qui est extrêmement efficace les
quatre modes l'actif track 5.0
personnellement j'adore la mise à jour
est très belle là-dessus la roue crantée
qui est vraiment juste la superbe idée
en termes de côté intuitif c'est
vraiment vraiment génial enfin bref vous
l'avez compris vous plein de ressources
un super boutique pour tous les
créateurs pour tous les créatifs qui
veulent venir filmer ici avec leur
smartphone je vous invite donc à venir
cliquer sur le lien dans la description
si vous voulez en savoir plus et si ce
produit vous intéresse et si vous avez
des questions des interrogations et
suggestions vous pouvez aller en bas
dans les commentaires merci à dji
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo et quant
à moi je donne rendez-vous très bientôt
pour continuer à parler tech bien
évidemment je vous embrasse bisous Ciao
[Musique]